[Musique]
mais
et
[Musique]
je vais mourir
je suis le secrétaire de dark vador
j'ai droit quelqu'un
juste
c'est l'occasion de sourire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque saison mais changer ton meilleur
déguisement de tout les temps je pense
que tu en a été autrement cette époque
là que des soirées à toutes les époques
un vampire et qu'un masque c'est un peu
le triste score mais s'est pour sa part
fermé non j'ai les dents
c'est vrai que personne ne t'a jamais vu
le jour
c'est vrai ça oui mais alors
[Musique]
le
on
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'étais bien
comment jeté les semences elle avait
rassemblé changer vos plans
ça change et ça fait si bon vivre à
jouer
je regardais telle qu'elle est
[Musique]
moi
d
[Musique]
à lumio dans la mode
elle